I was talking to Ronnie in the car about
his [ __ ] ring like I thought I thought a
[ __ ] ring was like metal no it's rubber
yes
I'm Ronnie tights elastic I said Ronnie
how many [ __ ] rings do you have sir in
all seriousness he was like oh yeah I've
like three they come in a three pack
it's like a rubber band yes and he puts
it around his [ __ ] do you remember
remember as a child when you rub wrapped
a rubber band around your finger and it
got all pink or purple yeah you stopped
the circulation that's what this thing
does well why would you want that on
your [ __ ] because it's supposed to make
your erection lasts longer it's like
putting on a rubber but without the
rubber part and it's got like a little
like ribs on it around and around the
whole thing what's the point of the ribs
okay kind of excites the girl supposedly
does it work did your girlfriend say hey
this feels really good
she doesn't even detect it no she
detects she knows it's there how much
does it cost for a [ __ ] ring I don't
remember you want me to bring the
package I'll bring I don't know you see
page you use the [ __ ] ring once and then
you throw it away no you mean you'll
wash it be honest with me do you really
bother to wash it or do you hand wash it
hand wash what with so with you know
that kind of hand soap stuff in the
bottle yeah I think that's how you wash
the Conquer washing real good and then
put it back in the package so anyway
just wipes it on the sheets and throws
it in the drawer dying to try to sit
with you so there's three different
sizes yeah so what if you really want to
have some real cool fun you take the one
[ __ ] ring you put it down all the way
down to the bottom you shaft the base
yeah the bottom half okay and then you
take the smaller [ __ ] ring go ahead you
put it like right below the head of your
[ __ ] okay and then it's like you're in
there
it's awesome really yeah told you it's
good just told me it's good Wow so how
often do you eat loves me man how often
do you put both [ __ ] rings on like how
often will that out once in a while like
what like five times a year maybe more
you ever announced to Stephanie I'm
gonna put two [ __ ] rings on listen to it
all depends on the mood you know how
work thought I was gonna say let's help
everybody
oh did you there's your girlfriend
hey Stephanie Stephanie I know Ronnie's
like um while he's mental so I have to
be careful how you answer but is Ronnie
correct that the woman benefits from the
[ __ ] ring or are you really not feeling
a difference no I do because it hits
different spots when he does a double
[ __ ] ring are you like oh this is
ridiculous or are you kind of into it
better it was one is good I'm good with
one you know if you like the double
that's fine with me to it you know it
doesn't make a huge difference the one
with the vibrant a little vibrator box
so now I call I call it the st. Bernard
how often you put that on your car and
once in a while what does that mean once
in a while special occasion it's like
we're really like you know hey you know
what would be a special occasion
Stephanie daylight savings
like I mean like this Ronnie go hey it's
a special occasion I'm gonna put my
vibrating hang on like how does that
come about it just happens watching
porno oh oh I didn't know you watch porn
yeah we watch panel boy Saturday night
yeah well sometimes she initiates you
know she'll go open up the little
cabinet
oh let's throw in a DVD right you know I
gotta tell you yeah that one's normal I
mean she's a lot of fun yeah why I love
her man like most women she's good yeah
don't yeah you know won't even close
Ronnie if I mention or any things about
his [ __ ] right what's going on is
marriage on the horizon I keep
encouraging Ronnie to marry you I know
we were talking about it this weekend
[Music]
I put the wedding ring on my god about
the process going to it yeah the process
of you know you get the ring and then
you know why are you talking about just
do it now why would you marry who else
is gonna play we have the court we have
a great relationship
go ahead why ruin it oh you think that
would ruin it I don't know yeah
Stephanie you want to marry Rani if you
asked of course I would you know but
then we were we were talking about just
doing the engagement for a while or and
maybe just having a party not actually
doing a whole wedding ceremony don't
wait too long yeah have you seen this
guy in my head
[Laughter]
a wedding / wake I think you should do
it I mean you know what seriously
Stephanie's stuck by you yeah not good I
mean yeah she a good woman make an
honest woman out of her but she'll
squirt out to the cake
we see each other man whatever
what was that if we would come would you
guys all come to the wedding
yeah I definitely go to that right now
Ronnie Ronnie Ronnie Ronnie
come on try it out wouldn't me try see
what happ what you would say there's not
much and what she really what would you
say she didn't ask me anything say
something I'll show your romantic side
here for once like what when you break
it down and tell this woman how much you
love her and they party for you well
that's no problem right I'll organise
that for everybody go ahead come on you
gotta have this she takes the concrete
dude you have to have two utensils when
you do that what would you say to her if
you were to propose all right you have
some fun good let's have some real fun
now yeah all right Stephanie go into go
into the office room uh-huh all right
open up my closet in the office room and
get in there Stephanie are you doing it
yeah okay you see my hat up there that
damn
up on the shelf it's on top of the
parachute I'm on top of the pair of
sneak its the derby hat okay yeah my
Derby hat take out the right sneaker
[Music]
take out the right sneaker okay take out
the box that's in the right sneaker as a
Steven singer on it
what is this okay all right
open up the box
holy [ __ ]
diamond-studded you Stephanie what's in
the box is that what I think what the
[ __ ] what is it what do you think it is
[Music]
what kind of ring this is look like it
looks like it's a big big giant
engagement ring like exactly who I
wanted okay so there you go now say
something so now it's been sitting there
for a while you remember at
Christmastime I told you I went to
Stephen st. gonna pick up my bracelet
and all that kind of [ __ ] yeah okay
so I got the ring and we've been talking
about it now I'm giving you the ring
Ronny pull your heart out and tell her
about your life together yeah well life
together is great and you know use [ __ ]
rings worse [ __ ] let me handle this
[Music]
I want you to know something you have
made me so happy and I God god bless you
for that I mean my life would never be
as full or is beautiful or as romantic
without you you and I are so right for
each other I believe and I hope you feel
the same way and what I'm saying in this
ring is I want to be yours forever and I
hope you'd be mine and I love you so
much
Wow
I am down on one knee Stefan write it
because I want to ask you a very
important question would you be my wife
will you be with me will you marry me
yes of course
I love you so much please tell me what
you're feeling inside yeah I want to
know what she's feeling with this
[ __ ] ring thank you thank you for
marrying me and I promise you I will do
everything to make our life together
spectacular and special yeah I know I'm
prank call and a girl named Stephanie
with your book Ronnie what she's in
tears now I know it's great does it say
does it fit yeah well you can thank your
boys over there for your wishlist they
know your size and everything and
congratulations on your Stephanie every
girl in America is not jealous of Ronnie
congratulations wasn't expecting that
[Music]
mrs. Mondt yes